- So something
that has been on my
mind and I wanted to make a
quick video about is I've been
reading so many of the
comments on social networks
about these teenagers,
these kids, they don't get it.
They're always on
their phone. (laughs)
You know, I'm blown away
by the establishment,
by parents, by the market,
by the elders and
even by some of the
kids within the age demo
of the gross underestimation of
this 11 to 16-year-old,
this 10 to 19-year-old demo.
What world do you think they're
gonna be living in in 2025?
And so all these critiques you
have about what they're doing
and they're not socially this
and they're not good enough and
they don't work hard enough.
I don't know what
you're paying attention to.
Watching these kids grind and
hustle and create content and
ideas and businesses
in these social networks.
Why don't you shut the fuck up
and go to Instagram for
three hours and stop judging and
pay attention to the explosion
of this creative hustler class
that is the teenagers and
the dominant
leaders of our future.